- take the Elizabeth Alexandra Mary take
the Elizabeth Alexandra Mary that's a
scene from the crown the Netflix series
that gives an intimate look at the lives
of Britain's Queen Elizabeth and her
husband Prince Philip were trade in the
first two seasons by actor Matt Smith
Smith is also starring in a vastly
different role in a new biopic on
controversial photographer Robert
Mapplethorpe i sat down with the actor
recently here at new york the star and
the gun is amazing in the robert
mapplethorpe gallery of New York's
Guggenheim Museum I've never seen this
one up close actor Matt Smith is
studying the artists work that's the one
I want in my house at the moment
why because just the angle of it is just
I find really satisfying and weirdly
it's kind of sexy Smith has the lead
role in the new film Mapplethorpe
photography is about light it's about
composition it's about the personality
of this subject I'm an artist that would
have been a painter but the camera was
invented the incendiary photographer who
died of AIDS in 1989 shocked even the
art world with his gay imagery your work
is so raw is she
I can't sell this I can't even show them
it was a steam train in New York he was
just had this ferocious talent and
capacity for life and amazing work ethic
would drew you to him I liked the fact
that he was what how to phrase this not
hugely likable in some instances yeah
you know quite singular and
uncompromising cruel perhaps at times
what gives you solace beauty knowing
that my work without living me I don't
think it watches moving oh my god Matt
Smith that's a great problem a perfect
impression you know but hopefully if you
know him and his work and his
temperament you'll see a degree of an
elements of his spirit come through
mm-hmm which is you know a rich and
brilliant defiant one
this is Royal Highness the Prince Philip
Duke of it Smith who just finished
playing Prince Philip in the Netflix
series the crown will next be seen as
Charles Manson in the film Charlie says
another one where you go you know
terrible casting on paper really but
I'll give it a whirl take the photo this
happy breed of men this little world
this blessed plot this earth this realm
this England you've been on a run of
playing real people I know it's weird is
why I'm gonna start him a case of Prince
Phillip young he's still alive oh yeah
why I mean just you know he's he's alive
and kicking man he's kind of similar to
Robert in many ways because you just
doesn't give a flying what's it about
anything good 97 I'm gonna drive why not
when you're playing somebody who might
actually be watching you yeah well it's
weird
although Phillip I think quite famously
someone asked him if he watched the
crown he said don't be ridiculous
the thumb just lay down the law I mean
Winston Churchill all that but remember
who you are the Queen of England
I'm not really the right class for
Phillip you didn't feel that way no I'm
not I'm not you know he's the you know
it's our I'm from a sort of
working-class British family growing up
in Northampton England Smith wasn't
interested in being an actor at first he
wanted to be a soccer player footballer
yeah he's a crack time when a back
injury ended those dreams a teacher
suggested the stage what did he see in
you I mean he cast me in a plague and I
didn't turn up and it was in a Drama
Festival at school and around my mum
that summer I was like I've cast him in
two things he said he's gonna come to
the classes and he hasn't I'm doing 12
Angry Men
can you please please make sure that he
turns up it's my mum said to me like you
should go to this you should do this and
I did and then I realized I quite liked
it
that's a fortuitous turn yeah luck then
and and I had a good teacher
in 2009 at age 26 Smith shot to stardom
in Britain when he was cast as Doctor
Who the eleventh actor to play the lead
role in the BBC's long-running sci-fi
adventure series for Doctor Who fans you
were a big surprise with a tricky time
yeah I've been walking down the street
in London and people love it I don't
break Doctor Who you were the youngest
person who'd ever gotten the part still
AM yes I really don't want to lose that
water really yes it's just I don't know
because it's in the Guinness Book of
World Records
it's my only real claim to fame I
thought you were hoping for more
children from me why on earth would you
do something like that to a head the
crown would introduce him to an even
wider audience but at first he was
reluctant to take the part honestly I
said who cares about a show about the
royal family why you're lost in your
role and you're lost in yourself but
then he saw the script and learned his
co-star would be Claire Foy as Queen
Elizabeth I realised that this marriage
has turned out to be something quite
different what we both imagined
understatement and Claire was cast and I
knew something of how brilliant she was
prison a lot of people about Phillip on
like on don't you think he's a real you
know I'm like no I love him mm-hmm I
love Prince Phillip when you play
someone you you invest in them day to
day so much that you can't help you know
mm-hmm I like him both Smith and Foy
were nominated for Emmys last year for
the crown
Claire Foy the crown but only Foy took
home a statue I dedicate this to the
next cast the next generation and I also
dedicate this to Matt Smith when she
went to me she thanked you
she did yeah yeah she did and when she
won a SAG Award you know thanks Claire
that's lastly talk cuz I never win
anything that's all I can do is thank
you on CBS give me crash now youyou like
Prince Philip no I liked his life his
roles and and I love that he plays real
people he finds that one thing yeah the
one thing to emulate in them so that it
makes you feel he's very good as Robert
Mapplethorpe and I can't wait to see him
as Charles Manson that's to be
interesting yeah